اذا هما الهجره واللجوء وسائل تبديل
الواقع والمستقبل في ايران لكن لدى الاوفر
حظا من الايرانيين طرقا اخرى تاسيسو
الشركات خارج البلاد طريقه يلجا اليها
الراغبون في الحصول على تذكره خروج مضمونه
في عمل 2020 و 2001 20 اسست
1661 الشركه في تركيا بمساهمه مهاجرين
ايرانيين قدرت قيمتها بنحو 22 مليون دولار
وخلال الاثنين 10 السنه الماضيه تم اصدار
البيت تاشيره لشركه ناشئه للايرانيين في
دولنا مثل امريكا والمملكه المتحده لكن
حتى هؤلاء لا يستلمون من بطش النظام يتقون
اطراف الحكوميه بمحاوله التجنيتهم لمصلحه
السلطات الامنيه بطريقه الترغيب والترهيب
والمره والامر ايضا ينطبق على جوه القلب
المهاجره كخلايا نائمه تبرم الحكومه عقود
عمل مع خبراء مغتربين لحجه تغطي العجز
الرسمي في الداخل والحقيقه كما كشف
الاعلام التركي ان المخطط تنفيذ عمليات
اغتيال
[موسيقى]
في داخل اول خارج الخطر يلاحق الايرانيين
وهذا ما يفسر ظاهره النفور او الهجره
الجماعيه التي لم تعد تقتصر على القامات
العلميه فقط العام الماضي انتشرت قصته
الارتفاع الجنوبي لمعادل مبيعات المنازل
في اكثر من منطقه تصنف راقيه ظاهره انقلبت
مفاهيم
سابقا حصلت سابقا الهجره على المقامات
العلميه دون غيرها في ايران الهجره
السنويه وصلت ايضا لرياضيين الفنانين
مثقفين كتاب مدرسين
كما ارتفعت بشكل كبير حالات الهجره
القصريه خلال السنوات الاخيره ما بين 20
الى 30,000 شخص
ينقطع تنقطع اخبارهم وتبقى مصائبهم مجهوله
اوراقه الثبوتيه بس طرق غير القانونيه
الوعره التي يبطرون لخوضها ما السبب تظهر
الاحصاءات العالميه ان معدل الدخل المواطن
العادي في العديد من الدول الاجنبيه
يفوقوا عشرات اضعاف ما يتقاضاه المواطن
الايرانيه في بلاده والهجره للجميع اذا
امر يظهره استطلاعه رايا لمركزي كيو انا
لاتكس رغبه الايرانيين في الهجره تفوقوا
المتوسط العالمي مرتين ليست رغبه فقط
بالواقع فنحو 17 في المئه هي حصه
الايرانيين مثلا في تركيا في 2020
و2012 من المنازل التي اشتراها الاجانب
والهجره خلال الفتره القادمه قد تصل
لمستوى الغير
التنبؤاتنا وفقا للادله المبعثره
والمنسجمه المعتمده على دراسات الميدانيه
قليله تفيد باننا نتجه للوصول الى احدى
قمم الهجره ليس لدينا تقدير على الاطلاق
كم من الوقت سنكون في تلك الدروع اعتقد ان
موجه الهجره هذه المره ستكون غير مسبقه
مقارنه بالعقود القليله الماضيه وحتى
مقارنه بما قبل الثوره ستكون هذه الهجره
غير مسبوقه